und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers einen
guten Sonntagabend ihnen allen es kommt
nicht so oft vor dass ein wahergebnis in
der Slowakei mit ihren 5ünfeinhalb
Millionen Einwohnern Kopfschmerzen quer
durch Europa auslöst heute ist genau das
der Fall denn Robert fizzo ist wieder da
derselbe Robert fizzo der von seinen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern vor 5 Jahren aus
dem Amt gedrängt worden war als Symbol
für ein politystem das von einer
brutalen Mafia unterlaufen wird jetzt
ist er Wahlsieger auch weil die
Regierungen nach ihm ein hilf und
heillos zerstrittenes Trauerspiel Boten
der neue alte starke Mann in Bratislava
punktet mit viel Kritik an der EU und
viel Lob für Wladimir Putin und so wird
der wahlaus he auch noch woanders mit
Sorge verfolgt nämlich in der Ukraine
ZDF Korrespondentin Britta
Hilpert um 4:0 Uhr morgens besingen
Robert fizzo und Parteifreunde ihren
Wahlsieg es ist das patriotische Lied
von einem Mann der sein Leben für die
Slowakei gibt Wahlsieger fiz fand es
wohl
passend entschuldigen Sie meine Stimme
sagt robertiz wir haben gestern lang
gefeiert er hatte wohl zunächst selbst
kaum vermutet dass er so klar gewinnen
würde robert fizo hat sich durchgesetzt
er kann wohl nach D Jahren Opposition
wieder eine Regierungskoalition bilden
und er will außenpolitisch andere Wege
gehen die Slowaken haben größere
Probleme als das Thema Ukraine ob wir
weiter Waffen liefern an die Ukraine
darum ging es nicht bei den Wahlen die
Slowaken haben große Probleme und die
sind unsere
Priorität bereitet eine kehtwende vor
beim Thema Waffenlieferungen zuletzt hat
die Slowakei sogar ihre Kampfflugzeuge
an den Nachbarn abgegeben gemessen am
Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist sie eine der
größten europäischen Unterstützer der
Ukraine doch in der Slowakei sind große
Teile der Bevölkerung prorussisch und
prorussische Propaganda seit
Kriegsbeginn kam noch hinzu fizo griff
sie auf und verstärkte
es keine einzige Kugel mehr für die
i dafür steht der Populist fiz darüber
haben seine Wähler die Skandale und
Korruption seiner letzten Regierung
vergessen Michael schimka präsentiert
sich als westorientierter Gegenentwurf
zu fizo er wurde Zweiter und will nicht
aufgeben wir werden alles tun um eine
Regierung fiz zu verhindern wir wissen
alle was so eine Regierung bedeutet für
unser rechts
undtische schon in der ersten
Fernsehdebatte nach der Wahl setzt fizo
ein Zeichen sein Platz ganz links bleibt
einfach leer er ist einer der seine
eigene Spur zieht der schwer einzubinden
ist auch ein Signal in Europa dazu
dringend Einigkeit braucht diese
Regierungsbildung so der Politologe bat
ist eine zivilisatorische
Entscheidung die Entscheidung ist
zwischen dem Osten und dem Westen also
zwischen einer ger einer einer langsamen
veröstlichung
Urbanisierung und putinisierung in die
eine Richtung und oder eben der
Möglichkeit dass die slowakische
Gesellschaft und die Slowakei als solche
den Staat weiterbildet und die liberale
Demokratie aufrechthält eine
putinisierung scheint wahrscheinlicher
schlechte Nachrichten aus Bratislava für
die
Ukraine
Marie Agnes stckzimmermann von der FDP
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
im Bundestag immer wieder als vehemente
Unterstützerin der Ukraine in der
Öffentlichkeit aktiv und jetzt bei uns
guten Abend Frau Stck Zimmermann guten
Abend wenn Sie die aktuellen Entwicklung
sehen bröckelt da gerade die westliche
Hilfe für die
Ukraine also das ist natürlich
besorgniserregend das was wir gerade
sehen das Wahlergebnis in der Slowakei
auch wenn es da eines eine Koalition
Bedarf wir sehen aber auch in Polen wie
innerhalb des Wahlkampfes sich auch sehr
distanziert geäußert wird der Ukraine
Hilfe gegenüber und auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten also ich hoffe nicht
dass sie bröckelt aber was uns natürlich
immer besorgt gemacht hat nämlich dass
wir gewusst haben dass die Zeit eine
große Rolle spielt und je länger der
Krieg geht je je mehr sozusagen Wladimir
Putin Zeit bekommt je enger wird es und
ich hoffe und befürchte äh oder ich
besser gesagt ich hoffe nicht und
befürchte dass das ein Problem werden
könnte vielleicht bleiben wir noch ein
Moment bei der Slowakei die war gemessen
am Bruttoinlandsprodukt einer der
größten Unterstützer in Europa Munition
Mick Kampfjets jetzt sagt der Wahlsieger
die Slowakei hat größere Probleme als
ukrainehilfe er werde nicht einen Schuss
Munition mehr liefern was heißt denn das
ganz konkret für die Ukraine wenn man
bedenkt dass die Slowakei ja auch sowas
wie ein Zentrum für Reparatur und
Lieferung von westlichen Waffen war oder
ist aktuell zumindest noch ja das das
wird die Ukraine natürlich zurecht
beunruhigen dieses Wahlergebnis äh aber
natürlich muss der neugewählte eine
Koalition aufbauen und dann bedarf es
natürlich auch dringender Gespräche
zwischen der Ukraine ich bin sicher dass
der ukrainische Präsident das machen
wird mit der neuen Regierung zu sprechen
so auch wie mit Polen denn das zahlt ja
sonst ein auf das was Putin ja gehofft
hat dass diese Allianz der europäischen
Staaten interessanterweise gerade die
die ganz nah an Russland dran sind also
wissen sollten dass wenn Putin Erfolg
hat mit seinem Übergriff auf die Ukraine
dass er möglicherweise dann natürlich
auch übergreift auf Polen bzw die
Slowakei und insofern gehe ich davon aus
dass Wladimir selenski besser gesagt
auch die Europäische Union dringend das
Gespräch suchen muss wie die Hilfe
weiter aussieht mhm volodomir selenski
meinen sie den ukrainischen Präsidenten
noch mal ganz kurz zur Slowakei die hat
ja ihr luftabwehrraketensystem und ihre
Mick kamplugzeuge an die Ukraine über
geben etwas was auch sie ja immer
gefordert haben Frau stckzimmermann
jetzt führt es allerdings dazu dass die
Slowakei den eigenen Luftraum aktuell
nicht mehr selbst schützen kann auch
Polen sagt er jetzt wir kaufen neue
Waffen erstmal für uns selbst nicht für
die Ukraine kann man das diesen Staaten
denn
verdenken nein ich glaube man kann
natürlich keinem irgendwas verdenken es
ist ja so dass auch die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland auf den Bestand der eigenen
Armee zurückgreift und
selbstverständlich muss jedes Land für
sich entscheiden wie weit die Hilfe geht
da steht uns auch nicht zu da Ansagen zu
machen aber ich bin zutiefst sicher dass
jeder Staat auch weiß dass ich
wiederhole mich ungern dass wenn Putin
mit diesem imperialistischen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff auf die
Ukraine Erfolg hat das nicht der letzte
Angriff innerhalb Europas gewesen ist
und das betrifft vor allem die Länder
die besonders nah an der an Russland
dran sind und das kann natürlich keiner
wollen insofern ist es von großer
Bedeutung dass Gespräche geführt werden
denn sie sprachen gerade den Ringtausch
an die Slowakei hat auch Material von
uns bekommen um wiederum die eigenen in
die Ukraine zu liefern und das bedeutet
natürlich dass es schnellstmöglich eine
Runde geben muss
wo das geklärt wird wie das in Zukunft
weitergeht der Wahlkampf jetzt in der
Slowakei war geprägt von einer
unglaublichen
Desinformationskampagne viele Experten
sagen das war aus Moskau gesteuert da
gab es eine unglaubliche Reihe von Fake
News in den sozialen Netzwerken ist ist
wenn sie sich das alles anschauen der
Arm Putins in Europa dann doch länger
als wir
denken also in den sozialen Netzwerken
ganz sicher wir wissen dass durch Trolle
schwer
versucht wird die öffentliche Meinung in
den westlichen Staaten zu beeinflussen
zu kontrakarieren das kann
möglicherweise mit einem Grund sein ich
will das jetzt nicht voreilig sagen aber
wir wissen dass diese sogenannten
Hybriden Angriffe deutlich über die
Ukraine hinausgehen also besonders die
Staaten eben wuschig macht die bereit
sind zu helfen und deswegen müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass auch diese Wahl
gesteuert wurde von Moskau ist übrigens
für uns auch für die kommenden Wahlen
die in Deutschland anstehen die
Europawahl die Bundestagswahl dass da
auch ein ganz ganz langer Arm reicht und
wir uns besonders schützen müssen um die
öffentliche Meinung eben äh ja dass die
eben nicht so beeinflusst wird von
Lügengeschichten von Trollen dass das
ein Ergebnis hat letztlich für die Wahl
wir haben hier in der Slowakei größere
Probleme als die ukrainehilfe sagt der
Wahlsieger wenn jemand in Deutschland
sagen würde auch wir hier in Deutschland
haben größere Probleme als die
ukrainehilfe was glauben Sie wie viele
Menschen in Deutschland fühlen sich
dadurch
angesprochen na ja das ist rein
prozentual schwer zu sagen Tatsache ist
natürlich dass wenn Menschen persönliche
Sorgen haben sich Gedanken machen über
das Thema Energie Inflation wie bekomme
ich eine günstige Wohnung also sich
darüber Gedanken machen was ein
persönlich unmittelbar berührt und
betrifft besteht natürlich die Gefahr
dass sie das große Ganze nicht mehr
überblicken oder auch nicht überblicken
wollen aber das ist natürlich unsere
Aufgabe Politik zu erklären ihre Aufgabe
als Medienpolitik zu erklären dass also
unser persönliches Wohlergehen nicht vor
der Haustür endet oder bis sondern dass
es eben weitreichende Folgen hat wenn
Putin mit diesem Angriff Erfolg hat das
ist unsere Aufgabe das zu tun ich
verstehe dass es Menschen gibt die
machen sich Sorgen die haben keine Lust
mehr diesen Krieg zu betrachten und zu
sehen tatsache ist aber dass in der
Ukraine nach wie vor gemordet
vergewaltigt verschleppt wird dieses
Land kämpft und es kämpft letztlich auch
für unsere Freiheit in Frieden sagt die
Chefin des Verteidigungsausschusses im
Deutschen Bundestag Frau Stck Zimmermann
vielen Dank für das Gespräch ich danke
Ihnen und wie in dem Gespräch das wir
aufgezeichnet haben ja schon mehrfach
angeklungen ist auch in Polen gibt es
eine Wahl mit enormen folgen in zwei
Wochen am 15 Oktober viele sprechen von
der wichtigsten Wahl des Jahres in
Europa ein Land das tief gespalten ist
zwei Kontrahenten die ja man muss wohl
sagen sich abgrundtief hassen und ihre
Anhänger zu Hunderttausenden auf die
Straße bekommen in Warschau heute ein
Meer von rotweiß klar aber auch ein Meer
von blaugoldenen Europa fahen es ist die
größte Demonstration die Warschau je
erlebt hat sagt das das Rathaus dazu
muss man wissen das Rathaus ist in der
Hand der Opposition die da heute
demonstriert während die EU große
Zweifel hat an der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
in Polen und der Regierung vorwirft die
Justiz zu untergraben ruft der
Oppositionsführer seinen Anhängern heute
zu es ist wichtig dass ganz Polen sieht
dass niemand mehr Angst hat aus Warschau
Natalie
Steger wer die zwei Welten Polens
begreifen will muss nur fern
rechts im unabhängigen TV die Großdemo
der Opposition links der öffentlich
rechtliche Nachrichtenkanal stramm auf
peaceelinie ignoriert die Demo überträgt
lieber den peace
Parteitag dabei sind es rund eine
Million Menschen die in Warschau
demonstrieren gegen die
nationalkonservative Regierung so wie
maor nach Jahren seh sie die politische
Wende
heri den Wahlen steht die Zukunft Polens
auf dem Spiel entweder Demokratie oder
Diktatur sie haben alles in diesem Land
gebrochen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Frauenrechte und
Verletzung der
Verfassung wir haben es mit Aktivitäten
zu tun wie in
Belarus seinen Namen skandiert die Menge
heute mehrmals Donald Tusk
liberalervaver
oppositionführer im Tonfall
kämpferisch
ergibt sich als Versöhner einer
polarisierten polnischen
Gesellschaft nicht nur diese vier Sachen
verspreche ich euch dass wir siegen
abrechnen Leid wieder gut machen uns
versöhnen sondern auch das Ende des
polnischpolnischen Kriegs am Tag nach
den Wahlen Tusk der ehemalige
euratspräsident will außerdem
warschausus angespanntes Verhältnis zu
Brüssel korrigieren genau das macht ihn
für die peace zum Verräter nationaler
Interessen ein aktueller peace
parteispot Tusk seit Jahren als
Marionette Berlins dargestellt das soll
hier wieder eingepeitscht
werden auf der Antideutschen Klaviatur
spielt auch der peace parteichf heute
wieder beim Parteitag in
katwitze wir wollen Reparationen von
Deutschland es ist nicht nur die
finanzielle Dimension die uns zusteht es
ist auch eine Sache unserer
würde
[Musik]
die peace verkauft sich als Bollwerk
gegen Migration verspricht soziale
Wohltaten sogar die Benzinpreise sind
auf Talfahrt es wird gemunkelt dass der
teilstatliche Ölkonzern die Preise
drückt bis zur
Wahl die Opposition im Sog der großen
demobeteiligung
zuversichtlich wenn ich dieses Mehr von
Herzen sehe dann spüre ich sehr wohl
dass dieser wendemoment in der
Geschichte unser
land in Warschau war aber nur die eine
Seite Polens auf der Straße in den
Umfragen liegt t bürgerkoalition auf
Rang 2 allerdings droh der peace der
Verlust der absoluten Mehrheit sie
könnte versuchen die Ultra rechten rüber
Zuziehen der Endspurt einer wahren
Richtungswahl hat
begonnen ja wir können gespannt sein wie
gesagt in Z Wochen wird in Polen gewählt
selbst Seen was ist mit eigenen Augen
vor Ort das ist die erste und die
wichtigste Leitlinie im Journalismus und
der Grund weshalb sie erwarten dürfen
dass wir alles tun um bei entscheidenden
Entwicklungen direkt vor Ort zu sein was
genau vor sich geht in der
Kaukasusregion Bergkarabach seit dem
Sieg der aserbaidschanischen Truppen
dort über die selbsternannte
armeniareublik das lässt sich auch nur
so wirklich herausfinden die reinen
Zahlen jedenfalls lassen nichts Gutes
erahnen fast alle der ehemals 120 000
Armenia dort sind mittlerweile geflohen
viele offenbar in
Todesangst ist das herzzerreißende
Flucht oder auch bereits gezielte
Vertreibung unser Reporter Sebastian ehm
will das Herausfinden vor
Ort wir sind unterwegs nach Bergkarabach
dort wo bis vor 12 Tagen noch Armenia
die Kontrolle hatten dort wo bis vor
kurzem noch über 100.000 Menschen gelebt
haben das was wir entlang der Straße
sehen sind Bilder eines langen Konflikts
und einer überstürzten
Flucht am Grenzübergang über den
ztausende nach Armenien geflohen sind
treffen wir jetzt nur noch einen Mann
Sergei 40 Jahre
alt soll ich etwa allein dort
bleiben meine ganze Familie ist schon in
Armenien wenn die anderen geblieben
wären oder wenigstens ein Teil dann
würde ich definitiv
bleiben
es seien kaum noch Armenia in
Bergkarabach auch seine Frau und seine
drei Töchter schon vor Tagen
geflogen die Leute haben Angst vor Krieg
vor Mördern es gibt ja keinen Krieg wo
Lebkuchen verteilt werden überall gibt
es Opfer die Leute haben Angst dass die
beiden Völker nie zusammenleben
könnenrine hat wahrscheinlich für immer
verlässt inszeniert der
aserbaidschanische Grenzschutz vor der
internationalen Presse eine
Wachablösung unsere Reise nach
Bergkarabach ist von den Behörden
vorgeplant trotzdem kommt es immer
wieder zu zufälligen Begegnungen der
Zeitpunkt der Reise dürfte kein Zufall
sein man will uns zeigen hier hat jetzt
Aserbaidschan das
Sagen in Gebiete wo sich noch Armenia
befinden lässt man uns aber nicht
offiziell aus Sicherheitsgründen wir es
den wenigen verblie Mens dort geht
unklar zufällig stoßen wir auf den
letzten Bus der geflüchtete nach
Armenien bringt die mehrheitlich alten
Menschen verängstigt und auch wütend auf
den armenischen Regierungschef pashinan
der ihnen nicht geholfen
hat das ist alles die Schuld von nicool
pashinan pashinan ist der schlechteste
Mensch der Welt monatelang waren sie von
der Außenwelt abgeschnitten dann griff
aseridsan an Kämpfen gegen einen
übermächtigen erschien inen zwecklos die
einzige Option für viele die Flucht die
siegreiche aserbaidschanische Armee
präsentiert uns am Abend die von den
Armeniern erbeuteten Waffen von einer
Vertreibung wie es die Armenier den
aserbeidschanern vorwerfen will der
Sprecher nichts wissen nein wir haben
niemanden vertrieben es ist deren Wahl
ich weiß nicht das müssen Sie die
Fragen Aserbaidschan behauptet jeder
karabacharmenier könne Teil ihres
Staates werden aber die meisten Armenier
fürchten sich vor Unterdrückung jetzt
ihre Zeit in Bergkarabach
vorbei weitere wichtige Nachrichten von
diesem Sonntag jetzt mit dir Hanna ja
und da blicken wir zunächst auf die
türkische Hauptstadt Ankara dort hat es
heute morgen nah des Parlaments einen
Bombenanschlag gegeben mittlerweile
bekannte sich laut einem Bericht die
verbotene kurdische Arbeiterpartei PKK
zu dem Angriff das türkische
Innenministerium sprach von zwei
Terroristen von denen sich einer vor
einem Eingang des Ministeriums in die
Luft gesprengt habe der zweite Angreifer
sei erschossen worden die Tat ereignete
sich wenige Stunden vor der
Wiedereröffnung des Parlaments nach der
Sommerpause der Deutsche Städtetag warnt
vor einem aus des deutschlandtickets
sollten Bund und Länder keine
zusätzlichen Finanzmittel zur Verfügung
stellen es sei absolut inakzeptabel dass
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing die
Mitfinanzierung der erwarteten
Mehrkosten im Jahr 2024 ablehne sagte
Hauptgeschäftsführer dedi der
funkemediengruppe der Verband Deutscher
Verkehrsunternehmen rechnet für das
kommende Jahr mit Zusatzkosten von 1,1
Milliarden Euro die Bundesländer hatten
sich bereits dazu bereit erklärt
mögliche Mehrkosten zur Hälfte zu
übernehmen der US Kongress hat eine
drohende Haushaltssperre in den
Vereinigten Staaten erstmal abgewendet
nur wenige Stunden vor Ablauf der Frist
stimmten Repräsentantenhaus und Senat
für einen übergangshaushalt dieser gilt
nun bis Mitte November der Entwurf für
den Kompromiss war vom republikanischen
Vorsitzenden des Repräsentantenhauses
McCarthy eingebracht worden gegen ihn
regt sich nun Widerstand in der eigenen
Partei die hartleiner kritisieren dass
der übergangshaushalt nicht die
weitgehenden bügetkürzungen enthält die
sie gefordert hatten gestrichen wurde
allerdings die
ukrainehilfe im spanischen msia sind bei
einem Brand in mehreren angrenzenden
Diskotheken mindestens 13 Menschen ums
Leben gekommen weitere Personen werden
laut Behörden noch vermisst das Feuer
war gegen 6 Uhr morgens ausgebrochen und
hatte sich schnell ausgebreitet die
Ursache ist noch unklar erst mehrere
Stunden später konnte der Brand gelöscht
werden nach Deutschland die
Bundesautobahn 66 von manchen auch
liebevoll Hessens Route 66 genannt geht
als rehein meain Schnellweg von der
Landeshauptstadt Wiesbaden in die
bankenmetrop Pole Frankfurt und dann auf
der anderen Seite von Hessens größter
Stadt weiter östlich Richtung fulder das
ist der Teil der weniger Aufmerksamkeit
bekommt aber viel zu erzählen hat Isabel
della Vega war genau dort unterwegs
Route 66 auf hessisch genau eine Woche
vor der
Wahl Frankfurt die
Wirtschaftsmetropole von hier aus
entlang der A66 starten wir unsere Tour
hier haben schon bei der letzten Wahl
viele AFD gewählt wie sieht es jetzt aus
Freigericht unsere erste Station die
Eisdiele im Zentrum paula vonseca ist
die Inhaberin wo sieht sie die Probleme
im Ort früher habe ich immer z.B nach
den Arbeit immer alleine gelaufen ohne
Angst heute habe ich Angst
wovor ja weil jede Ecke stehten Männer
mit Messer und also ich bin selbst
Ausländer ne aber wir sind in
Deutschland wir mussen die Deutsch
machen wir muss richtig integrieren und
alles machen wie die Deutsch fertig ob
sie die AFD wählen wird das weiß sie
noch nicht wir fahren weiter in Richtung
Osten Arm wirken die Orte hier nicht und
es gibt auch nicht mehr Arbeitslose als
woanders das Städtchen gellnhhausen hat
eine starke AFD erzählt uns Alexander
schopbach er organisiert deshalb jede
Woche eine Mahnwache gegen Rechts und
glaubt dass das Erstarken der recht in
der Gegend auch mit der ländlichen
Strukturschwäche zusammenhängt nehmen
sie den Ausbau des ÖPNV nehmen Sie die
medizinische Grundversorgung wir haben
dort also eine Verdichtung der
Problemstellungen die den Bürger direkt
betreffen und das macht den Bürger umso
anfälliger für den Wolf im Schafspelz
für die AFD nächstes Ziel eine
Wahlkampfveranstaltung der AFD in
badsodensal Münster Beatrix von
storchest da wieder steht das Thema
migra ganz vor so geht's also nicht
weiter W
überschwendt was eine
Regierungsbeteiligung der AFD in Hessen
denn da ausrichten könnte fragen
wir auf jeden Fall mal die
Grenzsicherung das erstmal wichtig das
können Sie schon mal machen und der Asyl
braucht der kann natürlich reinkommen
ist kein Thema aber dann nicht alle weil
wir für euch sind sind sie gegen uns wir
und sie und dazwischen wird der Spalt
immer größer das wird deutlich als wir
in Neuhof ankommen wir sprechen mit
Ilona und Carola ob sie auch AFD wählen
ja ja auf jeden Fall so mit dieser
ganzen Energiepolitik ne das ist das
kann man man kann nicht alles den
Bürgern zumuten dem arbeitenden Volk ne
und dann die anderen kommen kriegen
alles ne und ja nee so geht das nicht
ihre schwesteronbt nicht hier sondern in
Sachsen Anhalt ich würde die nie ums
Verrecken wählen und was denkst du was
die
machen ja die setzen sich fest und dann
haben wir wie 39 bis
4 nein das würde kein Mensch mehr
zulassen auch Simon Jürgen ist richtig
wütend auf die Regierung und auf die
AFD ich habe mich immer gefragt wie der
Adolf an die Macht gekommen ist aber
mittlerweile weiß ich wieer an Macht
gekommen ist d durch dass die
Bundespolitik einfach nur scheißeut auf
auf deutsch gesagt wird die AFD immer
stärker mit ihren populistischen Themen
Endstation fulder auf dem
Universitätsplatz verteilt die AFD
Rostbratwürste der Andrang ist groß und
die Flüchtlinge sind auch hier das
Aufregerthema ja die vielen Leute hier
und leben von unseren Steuern ja es ist
doch so weil sie verfolgt werden nee
also da gibt's ja auch noch andere
Länder wo man reingehen kann aber hier
kriegen seh Geld der AFD wächst auch die
Angst vor
ihr weil wir dann das hätten was wir
unter Hitler haben hatten nämlich einen
rechtslosen Start früher hatten die
Springerstiefel an und klatzen den
rechten Pöbel möchte ich nicht haben wir
fahren zurück mit dem Eindruck dass die
Zustimmung zur AFD aber auch ihre
Gegnerschaft entlang der A66 immer
größer
wurde jetzt was ganz anderes in dieser
Sendung nämlich sportliches an diesem
Sonntag Hanna ich bin gespannt in der
Fußball buundesliga gab es heute zwei
Begegnungen Darmstadt 98 traf auf Werder
Bremen und feierte seinen ersten
Saisonsieg entstand 4:2 und außerdem
spielte der SC Freiburg gegen den FC
Augsburg die Freiburger gewannen mit 2:0
auch für sie war es der erste Triumph
nach drei Spielen ohne
Sieg Überraschungserfolg für die
deutsche Springreiter Nationalmannschaft
das Quartett hat Barcelona das Finale
der Nations Cup Serie gewonnen auch
schlussreiter Richard Vogel auf hangst
United Touch s glänzte mit einer Null
fehlerrunde er sicherte so für das Team
den Sieg vor Frankreich und Belgien und
das nach einer eher enttäuschenden
Saison und jetzt wie immer an dieser
Stelle sie haben es bestimmt schon
erwartet gucken wir auf das was wichtig
wird der heute journal Ausblick von Jörg
[Musik]
bill
aus Protest gegen die aktuelle
Gesundheitspolitik werden am Montag
viele Orts die Arztpraxen geschlossen
bleiben zum wiederholten Mal fordern die
Mediziner bessere Rahmenbedingungen für
ihre Arbeit unter anderem geht es um die
Wiedereinführung der
neupatientenregelung sowie den
Bürokratieabbau in den prachxen 33 Jahre
deutsche Einheit das wird am Dienstag in
Hamburg groß gefeiert beim Bürgerfest im
Herzen der Stadt werden sich
traditionell die 16 Bundesländer
vorstellen
zu den Einheitsfeierlichkeiten werden
hunderttausende Besucher
erwartet die EU Regierungschefs werden
sich am Donnerstag zu einem zweitägigen
Gipfel im spanischen Granada treffen vor
allem der aktuelle Konflikt um die
Region Bergkarabach wird ein zentrales
Thema des Gipfels sein wie auch die
derzeitigen Spannungen zwischen Serbien
und Kosovo es wird die Woche der
Nobelpreise mit dem Höhepunkt am Freitag
dem
Friedensnobelpreis wie immer ist die
Liste der Kandidaten geheim angesichts
der zahlreichen bewaffneten Konflikte
rund um den Globus wird die Bekanntgabe
mit Spannung
erwartet der oktober zeigt sich zunächst
von seiner sommerlichen Seite die
Wetteraussichten morgen im Norden teils
dichte Wolken und im küstenumfeld etwas
Regen sonst sonnig und trocken
Höchstwerte zwischen 19 und 30° am
Dienstag teilweise noch ungewöhnlich
warm und von aufkommende Schauer und
Gewitter anschließend etwas kühler im
Norden wechselhaft im Süden
sonnig und jetzt ein Ständchen zum
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Geburtstag das Atlanta syfonieorchester
und alle singen mit für einen der mal
der mächtigste Mensch der Welt war und
dabei immer bodenständig blieb ein
erdnussf aus Plains Georgia er lebt
immer noch in dem 600 seelennest in dem
er geboren wurde und da feiert Jimmy
Carter heute seinen
99 gesundheitlich sehr schwach aber mit
seiner Frau seinen Kindern Enkeln
Urenkeln und Glückwünschen für einen der
als US-Präsident eher glücklos war aber
danach sein Land beeindruckt hat weil er
sich mit ganzer Kraft für die Armen und
Schwachen einsetzte auch selbst mit
anpackte beim Bau von Häusern für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen weil er
zu einem moralischen Kompass wurde für
ein tief gespaltenes
Land vor zwei Jahren haben rosalin und
Jimmy Carter übrigens ihre
kronjuwelenhochzeit gefeiert über 75
Jahre gemeinsam durchs Leben gehen
ebenso kostbar wie nicht zu
bezahlen die Macht der Liebe damit
schicken wir sie in diesen Sonntag Abend
nächste Woche sind hier Marietta Slomka
und Heinz Wolf für Sie da wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss